cindy and michael need one gallon of
orange paint for the giant cardboard
pumpkin they are making for halloween
cindy has two-fifths of a gallon of red
paint
michael has got half a gallon of yellow
paint if they mix their paints together
will they have the one gallon they need
so let's think about that we're gonna
add the two-fifths of red paint and
we're gonna add that to our two-fifths
of a gallon of red paint and we're gonna
add that to half a gallon of yellow
paint and we want to see if this gets to
being one whole gallon
so whenever we add fractions right over
here we're not adding the same thing
here writing two-fifths here we're
adding one-halves so in order to be able
to add these two things we need to get
to a common denominator and the common
denominator or the best common
denominator to use is the number that is
the smallest multiple of both five and
two and since five and two are both
prime numbers the smallest number is
just going to be their product 10 is the
smallest number that we can think of
that is divisible by both 5 and 2. so
let's rewrite each of these fractions
with
10 as a denominator so with 10 as a
denominator so two-fifths is going to be
something over 10 and one-half is going
to be something
something over 10. and to help us
visualize this let me draw a grid
let me draw a grid with tenths in it so
that's that
and that's
that right over here so each of these
are intense these are 10 equal segments
this bar is divided into
so let's try to visualize what
two-fifths looks like on this bar well
if we were to divide right now it's
divided into tenths if we were to divide
this bar into fifths then we're gonna
have so that's one actually let me do
that same color
so it's going to be
it's gonna be so this is one division
two
three
four
so notice if you go between the red
marks you are going these are each a
fifth of the bar if you go between the
red marks
and we have two of them so we're gonna
go
one
and two
this right over here this this part of
the bar represents two-fifths of it now
let's do the same thing for one-half
so let's divide this bar exactly in half
so exactly in half so let me do that
so i'm going to divide it exactly in
half
and one half liter represents one of the
two equal sections so this is
one
one half now to go from fifths to tenths
you're essentially taking each of the
equal sections and you are multiplying
by two so to go from fifths
to tenths you're multiplying by two you
have five equal sections you split each
of those into two so you have twice as
many you now have ten equal sections
so those two sections that were shaded
in well you were going to multiply by
two the same way those two are going to
turn into
those two are going to turn into four
tenths
four tenths
and you see it right over here when we
shaded it initially if you look at the
tenths you have one tenth two tenths
three tenths
and four tenths let's do the same logic
over here if you have two halves and you
want to make them into ten tenths you
have to take each of the halves and
split them into five sections you're
gonna have five times as many sections
so to go from two to ten to go from two
to ten we multiply by five
so similarly that one shaded in section
that in yellow that's going to turn into
five
that one half is going to turn into five
tenths so we're gonna multiply by 5.
another way to think about it whatever
we did to the numerator or whatever we
did in the denominator we had to do the
numerator whatever we did to the
denominator we have to do the numerator
otherwise we're changing somehow we're
changing the value of the fraction so 1
times 5 is going to get you 2 5. and you
see that over here when we shaded it in
that one half if you look at the tenths
is equal to one
two
three
four
five tenths and now we are ready to add
now we are ready to add these two things
four tenths plus five tenths
well this is going to be equal to a
certain number of tenths it's gonna be
equal to a certain number of tenths it's
gonna be equal to four plus five tenths
four
plus five
four plus five tenths and we can once
again visualize that let me
draw our grid again
so four plus five tenths i'll do it
actually on top of the paint can right
over here
so let me color in four tenths so one
two
three
four
and then let me color in the five tenths
and notice that was exactly the four
tenths here which is exactly the two
fifths let me color in the five tenths
one two
three
four
and five and so how many total tenths do
we have we have a total of one two three
four five six seven eight nine
nine of the tenths are now shaded we had
nine tenths of a gallon of paint so now
to answer their question will they have
the gallon they need no they have less
than a hole a gallon would be ten tenths
they only have nine tens so no
they do not have enough of a gallon now
another way you could have thought about
this
you could have said hey look
two-fifths is less than a half and you
could even visualize that right over
here so i have something less than a
half plus a half i'm not going to get a
whole so either way you could think
about it but this way at least we can
think it through with actually adding
the fractions